That's why the.
I don't know those two minutes
or so i don't need to. Limit.
You know why does he turn.
Like. Simon. Simon can.
Serve unless.
They tell me why i didn't
come to the aquarius
festival. I was working.
My name's limit and i've lived
here since permanently in 79.
And i heard about the squarest test for.
I guess there must have been a lot of
advertising or something like that.
Certainly people were talking about it
and i was working in this funky
vegetarian restaurant and.
We closed down so
that people would have the opportunity
to come up for the festival
and i made mine turned
up with some pink rocks.
And that was that there was no choice.
I had been going to hitchhike
up the coast from sydney and.
Camp and so on and i had a
lot of mates from school
and so on who were who were coming
because i'd left school for i think and.
I think it up using drugs.
Copious amounts there are for the the
time that the restaurant was closed and.
Then the restaurant reopened
and i got the sack something
and i think it was the first the first
job that i'd ever had and first.
First consequences of my addiction
but everybody else seemed to have a
really good time at the festival
and i ended up coming
up a few years later.
I think i've done my kid must've been
about eight months old i came up in the
travelling north and.
And we started tumble
and i remember trying to buy milk in the
morning because we'd run out of milk
and i had none. Myself
and i couldn't get anybody to say i'm
not the woman who was in charge of the
fucking cow wouldn't sell me because
it was about a clock in the morning
and she had other shit to do. And i
got so angry i was really pissed off
and i thought this is a really vile place.
And then come back for about four
years and then i moved back up here
and up here
but yet my sort of early experiences in
the world sort of negative in one way
or another even not coming here or
getting pissed off for the lack of.
Monash study. I'm sorry. Simon
cass. I mean the memory.
I came up i was i came up to the festival
in the original aquarius festival i was a
student at monash university
at the time studying economics
and politics.
And i was really studying revolution there
that's the main reason i'm going to
monash a lot lang was there was the
heyday of the entity of the anti-vietnam
and anti conscription
movement and the focus of
that fight seem to be coming
from monash so i went to monash
and i hung in there for a couple of
years and when that came to an end.
That came to an end was
that university choir. Yes.
First of all came up i went and i figured.
Basically i figured this
was the next direction
that the revolutionary was
was headed into the hills.
My career was a bit dicey my drug consumption
was sort of escalating and i thought.
You know the place for me is the
place for health for revolution.
And for the good life and i came up.
Went to the festival.
Went back to melbourne.
Took awhile to organize all
the staff and car girlfriend
and head up for this area
head up to this area and.
Moved in and basically i've
been based in this area.
Ever since couple of years
later i bought a share
and a ton of all lived there for a while
and i moved around lived in this been
based in this area. Ever since then.
To support.
I think jennifer i mean i think if
you're an addict you manifest drugs
like i mean they're you fuel and you
have to do it and that's just reality.
And so i mean i just did anything
that i needed to do to get drugs
and i mean in the early days it wasn't a
diet in assessing i didn't have to have
drugs on a daily basis.
I could just you know and occasionally and
so and i just i feel like we can use.
You know be nj. Yes. More like been
issues here and in latter days.
Fortunately street culture and
grown up enough so that one could.
Harass tourists on a daily basis and
and make a quick. No. So it wasn't.
I mean once that it happened it was
that it was a really easy thing to.
To survive in terms of your
addiction but prior to
that everybody just really just is
more erratic leader or you go off
and you get money in the city
and the city or whatever.
Yeah i want to know one of the reasons i
came up here was to get away from from.
Narcotics or so it's hard drugs.
And quite a few of my friends and up
in the hills the same reason. Whereas.
Our ideology equated.
Psychedelics as cool and.
As cool and acceptable
and part of part of the fight against the
established while we did pretty early in
the piece perceived narcotics
and alcohol and barbiturates
and pills as pretty much uncool
uncool as methods for the
establishment to control people. And
in those days we were pretty we want.
I mean we were we knew about the c.i.a.
Smuggling heroin out of there and we knew
all that we knew all the connections
and it was pretty taboo and. Well.
Where as we enjoyed the psychedelics we
we didn't really feel comfortable with.
Using and using their
colleagues and we did
that once again there was a
definite contradiction there.
What that there wasn't
with the psychedelics and.
Yeah that was one of the reasons i
moved up here was to get away from
that whole scene. I actually my
perceptions of melbourne at that time
or actually had i mean it was harder
and harder to get the mind
expanding drugs in melbourne
and more of the hard drugs of coming
in and and we looked upon that as.
You know as. A means of.
Pression a means of.
That weakening the sort of revolutionary
movement we felt was was happening at
that time and i think. I think
it's probably a big part of it.
I think i think you know narcotics
in places like the spike.
I think history proved that you know
those drugs have have affected.
Those elements of the society which are
most likely to be trying to change society
but yes a lot of people can't here
to get away from some hard drugs.
Up here.
A lot of it was.
For me personally is political
to be done well for me it was
basically trying to build to become
separate to become separate economically
politically socially to be independent to
not be dependent on mainstream society
for.
From everything from our basic material
necessities to our to our cultural to our
cultural consumption was to
build an alternative system.
I think we i didn't really i didn't perceive
i didn't perceive any real likelihood
of any violent revolution ever happening
in australia but i really thought
that we could perhaps build
an alternative society which.
Had a lot of those values that that that
i that i for mainstream society lacked
and so basically what we were about was
trying to build. A different system.
You know different schools different
economy. You know not plugged into the grid.
I mean not even. Same food.
I mean self-sufficient.
And independent from it.
Once again i think. Yeah.
I. I think i think grass.
Grass in particular was it was a great help
for a lot of people not all people for
a lot of people to get started up here.
I mean people didn't have any money.
There was no work.
There was no way to get a regular
income people to go away
and get a bit of a grubstake to
get started. That. After that.
That the only thing they could do to
supplement their income was social security
or seasonal work and. And
the extra few dollars that.
That a bit of grass brought in to the
families was enough to get the car the car
registered or the engine the engine
reboard or the tin for the roof
and i think for quite a few
people was a pretty integral part
and it sat at set ideologically it's a
pretty well with people because it was part
once again of building an
economy outside the mainstream.
And
that is.
You know i don't believe
that i don't believe
that you know vested interest became
involved or that you know any people.
Grew large quantities of doubts i mean i
don't think there was ever anything like
the grass castle syndrome
that say happening with us because i think
the ideology of the people engaged in
the action. Permeated the results in
that you know nobody wanted
fucking huge castle of anyway.
You know you wanted just some nice little
house in the forest you wanted good
gardens. Nobody wanted mercs nobody
wanted to have you know high tech videos
or anything like
that everybody had a notion of you know
leading a pretty sort of soundly principled
life based on on you know low
iq low economics and so on.
I mean if somebody did manage to pollute
to grow like you know a few pounds of
diodes. I mean nobody
knew what to do with it.
Probably a half of it away as their main
door they i mean everybody smoked a lot of
dope too so people were
sort of or had a party.
You know i think like i mean it was at
that thing of exchange too
like i don't know anybody
that i can think of around here
who who you know got heavy
or grew a lot of diaper or anything like
that like people might have just
built really nice houses but even
that you know like they did
a lot of that themselves
and they might have employed a mate to
do some so for whatever i don't you know
nobody ever sat around up here
in their patches with rifles or.
You know rabbit traps or anything like
that it was and i mean i think that
that sort of language has been.
All that sort of discourse has been
engaged in that i don't believe
but i just think that that
people would like to imagine
that sort of thing
happening up in the hills
but it's certainly not been my experience
and i've known you know a lot of
people growing dope for a lot of years
and it just seemed the people who were
talked about as you know inverted commas big
doug rose are just people living in shacks
who maybe sit on a pound of dope for a
year and that's their smoko for the whole
year they tournaments on and so on.
I never perceived it as
a big growth industry.
Other than you know a
sustainable kind of trip.
Four people to just live on simply
you know the sylvania waters type of
millionaire process
that's for sure. I mean.
Just the whole nature of the land up here
and the amount of people means that.
Basically people can't get away with large
with large plantar the nature of the
land and the amount of people around
here and people can't get away.
You know i mean people don't grow large
crops i mean they they grow in south
australia a couple of all the griffith.
I mean that's i mean large quantities and
have been busted up here i mean you know.
Dollar drug busts like somebody
got bought trays of seedling side
and some seedlings like
two inches high and
that i mean they've never ever
to be a full grown plant.
There's never been the plantations
that they've found in other areas where
there's never been the organisation i mean
the people up here all bunch of
anarchists i mean really about
that everything we ever managed to organise
with the defence of the forests move in
that i mean was very ad hoc going
to really had a hawk and and
that made it work to you
know like we were able to do
that so well because everybody could
just you know run around in the forest
and be crazy.
Basically i mean there was never about
a very sort of crime to be not there.
Made out the only sort of crime you ever
got up here was totally disorganized crime
you know on a really small
on a really small scale.
I mean even the kind of crime
that occurs in towns like i don't
think there's ever been many here
or there are people running around
stealing people's videos or anything like
that and i mean you could probably argue
that because of this is a bit of a dope
economy you know people can say in terms of
addiction support their habits here
and they don't need to sort of go
around with you know people's property
or anything like that. Yes. So. So yes.
By the driver further up.
The good doesn't happen
the drug problem it's a.
Well that's a drug problem
as i perceive it.
They say think
that the drug problem is you know a few
sort of really skinny looking ferals
and that you know that. Writer.
I think people see the drug problem.
As very singular like it's just you know
if you skinny ferals hanging around
outside the rainbow cafe
and that's a really horrific drug problem
whereas in fact nobody's being burgled.
You know nobody's videos are being taken.
It's just that we have one street cullen
street with a couple of offshoots.
And people sit on the street outside
the rainbow or outside the museum.
Or outside the tomato sauce
and sometimes they're pissed
and sometimes they're on the nod and
i'm not saying it's a pretty sight.
But it's it's a very small time drug problem
it's it's not anything particularly
serious and often you know i think
that the people aren't even on the nod
or pissed they're just sitting
there looking minutes.
And that would probably give the
kids a lot of pleasure to sort of be
that menacing and
and i know it must be really hard to be a
little old lady with a shopping trolley
walking down the street.
And having to walk through that little
bottleneck in front of the rainbow and.
I've actually recently suggested
that we extend the streetscape so
that there's several bottlenecks
there rather than just the one and
that way people can move
at random through it but
and it must be really scary
because they don't know
that you know this kid's just an 18
year old and he's just a goof head
or whatever you know they just see him
as a as a dirty threatening person and
that must be really hard but i mean they're
not they're not. It's not kings cross.
You know
and i'm also i think the dope problem is
just this catch phrase used to describe.
Runaway kids homelessness poverty psych
patients who have been kicked out
of halfway housing we've
got nowhere to go.
It's people we don't like it's the drug
problem is the drug problem are the other
that is the drug marginalised and
who haven't got anywhere to go and
that we don't want here in our nice town.
You know we want town to be a
fairly sanitary type of place.
And they wrecked so the
landscape architecture
and people don't see it in terms
of economics of a poverty
and homelessness they said in
terms of the drug problem.
You know whereas a lot of those
people have got a drug problem
and they just sitting there could
have got nowhere else to bloody sit
and nowhere else to go
and they've got i mean they may not have
much in their lives from our perspective
that.
You know like you don't have
to have much in your life
when you're 18 you just want
to hang out and hang around
and people people see all that and
rather than looking at the real issues.
The fundamental issues because of
all the needier high because of.
Because of you know the issues
of the vested interests.
The vested interests a pushing in this
town all these these complex social issues
that are occurring everywhere over the
whole western eastern world these days not
just nim and just come under
that the tidy problem.
The tide is heading of
the drug problem and.
I mean i think that's the hardest thing
because people do use do seen in as
separate as a different place and
that we shouldn't have these sort of problems
here we should have some kind of idea
leak kind of resolutely and model
of acting pastoral life you know
and it's ridiculous.
Like we have the same kind of
problems that that every you know.
Western capitalist nation has
and i mean we're just we're just a
microcosm of the tiny problems.
That other places have and i mean
why shouldn't it be any different.
I mean that's something that really
irritates me. Actually what i.
Private p'tite is it.
I think people have this notion that
nimbin is this fucking wonderful place and
and should be this sort of dream.
And that we're not we're just really
ordinary people and and the problems
that we have a ordinary problems like
you know mundane things like alcoholism
and drug addiction
and i mean they happen everywhere
they happen in i don't know cholera
and they happen in collins street and.
That's just the way it
is and i mean i think
that there are really positive things
that we can do about it you know
such as you know halfway houses
and drug education i think it's really
important to have drug education for teenage
kids and you know workshops for them and
and i think it's important to have a lot
of other things for our teenage kids were
a society here. That is is going to
have a baby you know like my kids 18.
He's in the older age category. My
brothers girlfriends. Twenty two.
She's one of the first set of
kids that went through and more
and more like around the 14 year old age
group where my nephews are we have a lot
of a lot of kids coming up and i think
that we need to sort of provide facilities
for them not just you know in regard to
sort of drug and alcohol
education or anything like that
but i mean like we've
got the youth club and
that needs funding i mean
kids in any country town.
Need a lot of things to do and again you
know i mean this is no different in
that and perhaps we can address
things in a more creative manner.
Than other country townsman we
can give them better things
and snooker tables you know but.
It's certainly something we're
going to have to look at
and i don't think you know that our
kids are going to be any different.
Most of our kids are going to will leave
most of our kids want to going to going to
want to you know live in the
cities and do the things
that city kids do most
sickly sort of in this
way. Well i think that
the nimbleness is is one
that is carried in the
hearts of many australians.
It's of the post 70s generation i
mean the call went out. Didn't it.
The call went out to. Those of us who'd.
You know grown up in the
60s and and many answered
that call you know people came
to him and i mean i think grown.
And joined a pretty good job of public
publicity and i mean i missed out.
Unfortunately but that was my own choice
probably. And i mean people came and.
And i think people had
a fucking good party.
They had a great party and that's
probably all it was i mean i think
that there's this this self importance
that takes place you know you know in
people's minds where they where they have to
sort of.
Build up their used to make it
meaningful or something like that and
and particularly you know like those who
left those who just came for the party.
They went away and they wanted to see
that they took place in something
meaningful for once in their damn lives and
and so you know this miss about nym
and girl offers as you know the repository
of failed dreams or not you know
and i mean i think it's really difficult
for those of us who actually live here
because people expect us to sort
of behave in in a certain way.
You know to be some kind of
you know visionary society
to live out those ideals of the 70s
and i mean basically it's the 90s i don't
i don't see why i should have to live out
anybody's vision. Other than my own
and you know my own vision is as you
know fairly small time and personal
and i like living here
it's a great place to live
but i certainly don't see it in any in any
noble terms and i don't see it in any.
You know particularly idealistic
terms i mean i do think that.
I do think that the
personal is political and
that you know you live out
your politics in your life.
And you can only do that in a
really really small way in effect.
Those that are really close to you and.
I don't know i mean i think
something really weird went on.
Nimbin
and people who were
probably really good at at
publicity
and i mean we've all got sort of fairly
public skills you know people who sort of
were trained in the sort of seventies and
and i guess we've got the
numbers too i think that
that people kind of did develop a myth
about what mean and was and and its place.
I mean i think it it occupies
a lot a much larger need.
Then it then it could you know
possibly ever kind of feel i think
that it looms large in people's minds really
unnecessarily you know like it's just
a place where people live.
It's a country town and i mean most of
us a fairly well-educated who live here.
I mean there was you know a real element
of of of people who were very bright
and very middle class kind we live
and so we've probably got in terms
of brain the top heavy town
but you know that's that's about it.
I don't i don't think there's anything else
going on here other than you know a few
bright people sitting around
having fun and living their lives
and there's still that focus. I guess
it's you know it's good for publicity.
It was good for the p.r.
In the 70s when it happened in that
you know there were a few naked tits
and bottoms around
and you know we're still bearing ourselves
to the national psyche god for v.
Our time bill that people have to
fucking listened of people about sex.
What do you still we all die.
But i think it's part of the limits goes
both agree what of people come here.
They've taken the women mr ha.
My come here and always expectations
about what they expected to be
when it doesn't live up to their their
expectations their dreams their allusions i.
They blame in i've blown in the
north. I blame. Dramas like i blame.
All this. I think that happens
when people you know say couples
for example move to the country
and think again the going to have
this you know we so in model.
So start they have to spend
24 hours a day together.
The kids are at home with them often.
You know the sexually vision
of labor comes into play
and then their lives fall
apart and they split up
and they did back to the cities
having had a ghastly time and
and again they blame whatever.
But i mean we've lived here with those
ideals and those ideals of change.
I mean we came here with a
lot of those original ideals
and we've had to put those
ideals in the practice
and what we've come up with now 20 years
down the line is as a result of putting
those ideals into practice and they've
changed considerably and reality
and the reality of living here the
reality of the changing economic times
and social times and growing
older and children.
We don't use tobacco leaf toilet paper
anymore dinner has changed. I mean.
You know we came here we have
these ideals originally as well
and i mean we're just adapted to
reality and. I mean life goes on.
I mean you've just got to live a normal
life and i mean you can do that.
You know with the practice
of change happening to you
and just because i feel just because
the way we live. These days doesn't.
Doesn't coincide with a lot of people's 70s
illusions about what i'll turn his life
should be and because i see you know.
They're all savages and not noble
savages on the side nimbin i mean
that they then they then think
that the whole dream is filed
and the whole thing as a disaster
but really it's just it's just changed i
think that the fact that it's gone on
and i think that it and turn
it has adapted basically prove
that it's still alive and
well and it's still growing.
You know that changes fashion
because 70s fashion is velvet.
It's and flowing locks is
really what people are used to
and then you know it a bit surreal
staggering jury comes out people find
that really confronting like i was listening
to somebody the other day going on
about some some girl had
a bone in their nose
and it was just like i was so horrified
i really profoundly disturbed by it
and again it's just like that is exactly
the same as we were 20 years ago
and i mean that's great. I love that.
But that you know life can
evolve and that kids.
I mean our kids have got something new
to do rather than wearing you know.
Boring velvet and. Like you.
You know. You know diction and.
The fact that.
You can i think you know i think.
The statement. Yeah. Yeah well.
Drugs are a very large part
of my life of for the first.
12 or 13 years that i lived
here and. On every level.
You know socially economically.
They were they were a large part and.
And i think i think i
needed you know i don't
regret those days i think there
was good times and bad times
and there was tragic times but. I think
that was what i needed to go through to to.
To spiritually grow to evolve i mean
that whole drug thing something
that i needed to go through and
come out the other end and
and really it's something
that i had to experience
and it's it's no good you know
counselors or judges or parents
or anyone telling me what was
right and what was wrong
and what was going to happen. Basically
on. I had to go through it and.
I went through it and
came out the other end.
Probably a lot stronger
and better off for it.
Other people had and i mean other people
died along the way i was lucky i think.
I think compared to a lot of my friends who
stayed in the city. I think living in.
Living in this environment
and in this community we're issues
were a lot more open and discussed
and.
Yeah i think i think i probably survived
my addiction a lot better than a lot of my
friends in the city did and i think.
You know on all levels on
particularly health wise.
Emotionally i wasn't as i
wasn't isolated in the
community here because of my diction
and i was i was taken for who i was
and what i did not the fact that i
was just an addict. You know it.
As time went like now you know addicts
are vilified pretty much and but.
In the general society but in the
alternative community over the years
when i was using. Not so much you are
basically if you're an addict i mean that
that that came second to who
you were and how you acted.
And so yeah i think.
I think i was definitely better off
being an addict in the country
but i was in the city.